[Applause]
welcome to swipe here's what's coming up
for you this week
Thomas visits the new home of
battlefield technology and its location
might surprise you I meet a man who used
to be homeless until a new website
changed his life and tamar's got the
video games you should be trying out
this weekend that's all to go Marco look
at some of our favorite tech stories of
the week science lovers look back on the
life of world famous British physicist
Stephen Hawking who died on Wednesday he
was 76 and had motor neurone disease in
his early 20s doctor said had only lived
for a few more years he went on to
become a father of three and
best-selling author helping us to better
understand the universe cyclists are
being warned to be careful about the
data they share on ride tracking apps as
it could be helping bike thieves
police say mapping programs might be
used to target high end bikes given that
you can see where the riders begin and
finish their cycle Apple keyboards could
soon become crumb proof the tech giant's
files are patent for keyboard designs
that would stop dirt and bits of food
getting stuck under the buttons there's
also a proposal for a spill proof
version and happy birthday to the World
Wide Web this week marks 29 years since
Sir Tim berners-lee wrote his proposal
for a new information system his
supervisor at the time called the idea
vague but exciting next up this week we
joined Thomas who traveled to Staines in
Middlesex which has become the unlikely
home of a cutting-edge future
battlefield technology we were
developing wearable technology before
anyone even had coined the phrase
wearable technology
it's taking us quite a while but we're
finally there we like can't and dec we
all right success for Stan and Asha may
have been a long time coming but success
it is thanks to a chance encounter with
the Canadian military at an Exhibition
their product is now making it into
Armed Forces the
/ the problem is that soldiers have a
lot of cables on them because they have
so much electrical equipment that
they're wearing now and soldiers hate
cables because they tangle because
they're always the first thing to break
because they got snagged on the inside
of vehicles that kind of stuff so they
saw that there was a real need for an
for a solution like the conductive
textiles the conductive fabric the duo
have developed allows electronics to be
built directly into clothing creating an
invisible network that integrates
devices power and data the partnership
may have once seemed an unlikely one so
I'm a weaver a knitter
I went to Central Sint Maartens lovey
and to do fashion and textiles and but I
was always really very interested in the
construction of textiles so I'm a design
engineer so a jack-of-all-trades
engineer bits of science and technology
bits of design and technology so I
suppose design was the common language
that Asha and I had that led us
communicate and let us start working
together so we came up with the idea
originally of creating this tiny little
switch into the surface of the fabric so
we wove with two conductive yarns that
formed a tiny little mechanical switch
into the surface of the fabric and
that's how we created everything else so
it's a UK developed technology by us
it's a large multinational that's
British base the weaving is done in this
country the finishing and cutting and
the making of the garments is all done
domestically within the UK so we think
it's a real real UK industry
successfully I mean let's face it the
problems come about because soldiers are
carrying lots of electronic equipment
now and it's a pain to keep it all
charged or change batteries for it all
and that's exactly the problem that all
of us now are facing out on the streets
that we're carrying so many phones and
backup battery chargers and headphones
and all of these things that somehow
need to be networked together and
wouldn't it be sensible to do that
through the clothes that you're wearing
so what's next what's the future we've
got so many exciting things that we
probably can't talk about but we love
challenging the boundaries so still
carrying on Charlie
the bandwidth there's still a lot of
work to be done with this with the the
products were doing bisoder systems what
really matters to is is to getting it to
the soldiers so that they can do their
jobs better so they can concentrate and
so hopefully they can save lives through
using this technology and it's nice we
work in our shed so it's pretty cool
Thomas Newton Sky News now at the end of
last year a website that lets you
sponsor a homeless person so that they
can get training and then find a job
with more than 300,000 homeless people
in the UK I was wondering just how
successful the new platform was proving
to be yeah just got my first place in
August this time last year
Joe was living in temporary
accommodation without work now he's got
a job as a crane rigger
helping extend one of London's tube
lines this crane right there I'm working
with that crane his training was paid
for by strangers who sponsored him
through a platform called Bing did you
see yourself I did I looked at myself
and I was checking Joe was referred to
the site by one of his key workers and
within five days volunteers had pledged
enough money to cover his job training
that felt amazing our fault with this
new thing because I was their second
member of us I thought this is gonna
like take four months or whatever and it
come around in five days I was fully
funded and ready to go in a training and
look these are all the messages from
people leaving you money each one yep so
you see this and you see people doing
things for you and you just think it's
amazing so you know it does give you
that extra bit of hope that you need I
would love to me every single one of
them the crowdfunding site was set up by
Alex an entrepreneur who told me that
helping homeless members pay for their
training it means they can earn a better
salary in a skilled job rather than
starting at the bottom here we have
Hannah who is training up as a
beautician and Leo training up as a
teaching assistant there are more than
20 members on the site and since
launching around six months ago beam has
helped three people get back into work
it's quite a slow burner when you say
well if you're gonna make the proper
investment into people to allow them to
good living to really move the on
homelessness then there's not a quick
fix it's not a one afternoon course or
one week course and what we're doing
here is we're allowing the public to
make a really smart investment in
someone's future and that might mean
that they're training for three or four
months users can choose to donate to one
person or to everyone on a site and in
return sponsors get updates and photos
about a member's progress beam is only
available in London but the plan is to
expand so long as it continues to get
enough backing with the goal of creating
many more success stories like Joe's I
have been so lucky son believable mix
for me is going into driving the cranes
would be a step up for me and just
finding myself in life taking my
daughter on a holiday and just getting
my life back together we've reached that
part of the show where we like to ask
you to forget all about reality and get
your gaming radar in check we've got a
mix of mobile PC and console offerings
for you is two more
into the breaches a PC game that fans of
the strategy genre are absolutely gonna
love you take control of three mechs and
are charged with taking our alien
invaders that sounds simple but it
actually requires a lot of forethought
and strategy
all of the buildings contribute towards
an overall energy grid and every time a
building takes damage you lose one unit
of energy from that grid if it all goes
away the enemy's overrun the entire
world and it's game over over time you
will lose that's what this game is about
but when you do lose you're able to take
one character and respawn the entire
timeline with them
this means that you've got the knowledge
of how to behave and how to use that
character and hopefully you can do
better on the second time through so
into the breach is an easy simple game
that you'll be playing for a very
extended period of time axiom verge has
actually been out on a number of
platforms for a while now but I only
recently got released for the Nintendo
switch which is good because it's
actually the perfect way to play that
game axiom verge is inspired by a
Nintendo classic called Metroid and it
wears that inspiration very proudly it's
a game where you wake up in a strange
alien world and like Metroid it's all
about losing yourself in that world you
explore and over time you uncover new
tools and weapons and that opens new
doors for you as you make your way
around the world you build this kind of
mental map of everything and over time
you'll defeat different bosses and
enemies and eventually come to master
the overall world axiom verge is very
much inspired by HR Giger work so if
you're a fan of aliens you'll love the
aesthetic
part-time UFO is developed by how
laboratories a studio known for working
with Nintendo on Smash Brothers and
Kirby they're known for taking simple
quirky ideas and making them endlessly
replayable and that's exactly what
part-time UFO does essentially it's a
crane game where you play as a UFO but
instead of using a crane to pick up
prizes you're actually using it to do
odd jobs and earn pocket money over time
you'll stack cheerleaders on top of each
other so they're in the proper formation
you go to a museum and help put back an
art installation into the correct order
and you'll even make a salad part-time
UFO is incredibly enjoyable it's really
cheap it's available on the iPhone and
it's good wholesome fun that's it join
us again for more swype next week in the
meantime follow us on twitter at sky
news white bye bye
[Applause]
you